welcome to the hubermann lab podcast
where we discuss science
and science-based tools for everyday
life
i'm andrew hueberman and i'm a professor
of neurobiology and ophthalmology at
stanford school of medicine
today we continue in our discussion
about sensation
or how we sense things on previous
episodes we talked about sensing light
and sound waves for things like
vision and hearing today we are going to
talk about our sense of self
or what's called interoception
interoception
is our sensing of our internal landscape
things like our heartbeat
our breathing and our gut how
full our gut might happen to be or how
empty our gut might happen to be
but also our inner landscape with
respect to chemistry
how acidic or how good or bad we feel on
the inside
this discussion about sense of self and
interoception has many
important actionable items that relate
to bodily health
and brain health and believe it or not
our ability to perform well or before
or perform poorly in life indeed
it has profound influence on our rates
of healing
so today we are going to talk about all
the aspects of our inner landscape
and how our brain and body communicate
and there will be many actionable
protocols
as we go along that discussion before we
begin our discussion about sense of self
i want to highlight some very recently
published research findings
that i believe are immediately
actionable
and that everybody should be aware of
these are data that were published by my
colleague justin sonenberg's laboratory
at stanford university school of
medicine
and the data were published in the
journal cell which is a very
very high stringency cell press journal
so phenomenal data
what the study showed was that
individuals given a high fiber diet
actually experience less diversity of
what's called the gut microbiome
the number of positive or health
promoting bacteria in the gut was
actually reduced by a high fiber diet
whereas individuals that ate just a
couple of servings of fermented
food each day experience important
and beneficial increases in
anti-inflammatory markers and that could
be traced back to
improvements in the gut microbiome
diversity
the diversity of bugs literally little
bacteria that live in the gut which
might sound bad but they are
actually very health promoting i'm going
to get into all the details of this
study
later in the episode but i just wanted
to emphasize these findings because
they are immediately actionable i think
for most people ingesting one or two
servings of fermented food each day is
reasonable
and does not bring with it tremendous
cost or
tremendous inconvenience and i think
many people are ingesting high fiber
diets thinking
that that's the best way to improve
their gut microbiome
so while these data may prove to be
controversial among the
folks out there in the nutrition
community that really promote high fiber
diet
i want to just emphasize that these data
were looked at in a very unbiased way
they were done with large scale
screens of all sorts of inflammatory
markers there was no specific hypothesis
going in it was purely exploratory
but the data are very very clear it
doesn't mean you shouldn't eat fiber
doesn't mean that fiber is bad
but it really shows that eating
fermented foods just one or two servings
a day
and maybe even ramping up to three or
four servings per day can be very
beneficial for many aspects of health
before we go any further i'd like to
emphasize that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research roles at
stanford
it is however part of my desire and
effort to bring zero cost to consumer
information about science
and science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme i'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast
our first sponsor is roka roka makes
sunglasses and eyeglasses that are of
the absolutely highest quality
the company was founded by two
all-american swimmers from stanford and
everything about their sunglasses and
eyeglasses
is developed with performance in mind
i've spent my career working on the
visual system
and its various functionings within the
brain and within the eye
roca sunglasses and eyeglasses are so
phenomenal because
they allow the visual system to do what
it does best which is to adjust
to changes in what we call luminance or
brightness
with many sunglasses out there and with
many eyeglasses as well
if the brightness in the room changes or
you get cloud cover or you walk into a
shadow
you have to take the glasses on or off
you can't see as well but the folks at
roka really understand how the visual
system works and so they've designed
their sunglasses and eyeglasses
such that you never experience that
shift you can walk into a shadow the
amount of sunlight can change you can go
into a dark room etc provided there's
enough light to see you're going to see
everything
crystal clear in addition you see
everything crystal clear because the
lens quality is terrific
and the sunglasses and eyeglasses are
very lightweight so you don't even
notice that they're on your face
also the sunglasses and eyeglasses are
designed for performance you can use
them while running
or while cycling even if you sweat they
won't slip off your face and as i
mentioned before they're very
lightweight
so everything about these glasses is
terrific and they have a terrific
aesthetic
they have a lot of different styles to
select from and unlike a lot of
performance eyeglasses out there
they won't make you look like a cyborg
you could wear them to dinner to
somebody's home and they look really
nice
if you'd like to try roka glasses you
can go to roca that's
roka.com and enter the code huberman to
save 20
off your first order that's roka
roka.com and enter the code
huberman at checkout today's podcast is
also brought to us by
inside tracker inside tracker is a
personalized nutrition platform that
analyzes data from your blood and dna
to help you better meet your health
goals i'm a big believer in getting
regular blood work done for the simple
reason
that many of the factors that impact
your immediate and long-term health
can only be assessed can only be
measured from a quality blood test
and now with the advent of quality dna
tests you can get further insight into
the status of your immediate and
long-term health
one of the problems with a lot of blood
and dna tests that are out there however
is you get the numbers back you get the
levels of metabolic factors hormones etc
but you don't get any information about
what to do with those numbers or how to
actually shift them in the direction
that you want to
with inside tracker they have this very
easy to use
dashboard and that dashboard makes it
very clear not just what your levels of
hormones etc
are but what actions to take in terms of
nutrition
or exercise or other lifestyle factors
to bring those numbers into the
appropriate ranges for you
if you'd like to try inside tracker you
can go to insidetracker.com
huberman and if you do that you'll get
25 percent off any of inside tracker's
plans just use the code
huberman at checkout that's
insidetracker.com
huberman to get 25 off any of
insidetrackers plans
today's podcast is also brought to us by
headspace
headspace is a meditation app that's
backed by 25 peer-reviewed published
studies
and has over 600 000 5-star reviews
i started meditating when i was in my
teens but for many years i found it hard
to maintain a meditation practice
i don't think i'm alone with that i
think many people start meditating
they'll do it for a few weeks or a few
months or maybe even a year
and then they'll give up the meditation
practice and we know from so many
peer-reviewed studies
that meditation has a number of very
positive
effects on our brain health our ability
to focus and our bodily health so it's a
great thing we probably should all be
doing it but most of us
including myself have found it hard to
stick to a meditation practice
then i started using the headspace app
and what i found is i could be very
consistent with my meditation practice
because
they have meditations that are short
meditations that are medium length and
meditations that are a bit longer all of
which benefit me
the meditations that they have also are
of different styles you can try
different forms of meditation
i particularly like having a guide for
my meditation it just helps me stay
focused helps me stay on track
and i'm able to derive all those regular
benefits of meditation and keep the
practice up
on a regular basis if you want to try
headspace you can go
to headspace.com special offer and if
you do that
you'll get a one month totally free
trial and with that you'll get all of
headspace's meditations the full library
of meditations
you just go to headspace.com special
offer and you get all of their
meditations for
one free month and you get to try if you
don't like it you can stop but i think
you will enjoy it
i certainly enjoy meditation and we know
that it's very beneficial for all of us
if you're somebody who cares about your
immediate and long-term health
and if you're somebody who's interested
in performance of any kind in work in
relationships
etc today's topic i believe is among the
more important ones for you
of all the topics i could cover this
thing that we call sense of self
which is also called interoception has
perhaps the most
foundational level of importance for all
that we feel
all that we do and all that we are
capable of doing
in fact i will go so far as to say that
interoception or
our ability to sense our inner real
estate
is right there next to sleep and perhaps
one other feature of our health
and bodily function that primarily
determine
how good we feel in the now in the short
term
and in the long term and sets the stage
for everything we are capable of doing
and if we don't take care of this thing
that we call interoception
just like if we don't take care of sleep
we cannot perform well
and we will not remain healthy
interoception and sense of self are
essentially the same thing
i will use those terms interchangeably
at least for sake of today's discussion
and i promise that if you can learn a
little bit about the mechanisms
of self-sensing of understanding what's
going on in your
internal milieu as we say your internal
environment
you will position yourself to do some
very simple things
that can lead to outsized positive
effects on everything from sleep
to body composition to mental focus
to mood your ability to regulate stress
and indeed even your ability to heal and
recovery from injuries of different
kinds brain injury and bodily injury
so sense of self is absolutely crucial
it's sometimes called our sixth sense
right alongside the other five senses
like hearing vision touch
taste smell etc but sense of self is
different
sense of self is really about what's
going on internally
within the confines of our skin and it
involves
two key features that if you can
understand those features
and you understand what modulates or
changes our ability
to sense those features there are a lot
of things that you can do
in terms of how you structure your
nutritional practices
how you relate to your exercise
practices
perhaps even certain things that you
take in terms of supplementation
that can basically make you feel better
more alert
and more capable for everything i don't
think that's a hyperbolic statement
in fact i know it's not a hyperbolic
statement because we have a system in
our body
that connects our brain to all of our
bodily organs
and connects all of those bodily organs
to our brain
and that communication between brain and
body in both directions
creates a situation where either we are
positioned to do things well
or we are positioned to do things poorly
so i really want to dive in and dissect
what is this system of brain body
communication what does it look like
what are the actual neurons and
connections
and as i do that i promise that i'm
going to place protocols
tools that you can apply in order to
make sure that those neurons and
connections are working optimally
so let's begin by talking about what
system
communicates the brain to the body and
the body back to the brain
the system that's most often associated
with this is our 10th cranial nerve
called the vagus nerve the word vagus
relates to the word vagabond which is to
wander and indeed
the vagus nerve is a vast enormous
wandering set of nerves so it's not one
nerve it's not like one fiber one axon
as we say
in the nervous system we have these
wires we call axons that let neurons
communicate
it's a bunch of neurons and a bunch of
wires that go everywhere so where do
they go
well they leave the brain and the brain
stem the brain stem is kind of the back
your brain if you touch the back your
neck it's about
three inches deep to where you're
touching the neurons that are there
send information into the body to
control your bodily organs
how fast your heart is beating how fast
you're breathing how fast your digestion
is occurring
even things like whether or not you are
going to secrete so-called killer cells
your immune cells from your spleen to go
ward off bacteria
now the neurons there don't know what to
do unless they receive information about
what's going on within the body
and within the body your heart your
lungs your diaphragm
your gut so everything from your
intestines to your stomach etc
and your spleen are sending information
also up to the brain
so as i mentioned before it's a two-way
street so the vagus nerve
is a very important nerve but just by
saying vagus nerve
it sounds like a singular it sounds like
one thing but actually what we're
talking about
is a series of super highways it's like
google maps it's got stuff going
everywhere with alternate routes
communicating back and forth
there are two fundamental features of
what's going on in your body
that need to be communicated to your
brain these neurons in your brain stem
in order for your brain and your body to
work together correctly
and the two types of information are
mechanical information
so things like pressure things like
lack of pressure and chemical
information
whether or not your gut is acidic or
whether or not it's
not acidic whether or not you have some
sort of pathogen you know something that
you ate or that got into your body
somehow
and is making you sick or whether or not
you don't have a pathogen in your body
so you've got mechanical sensing and
chemical sensing
so when you think about your sense of
self and your ability to understand
what's going on in your body if you feel
good or
if you feel bad your sense of self is
dependent on these mechanical
phenomena and these chemical phenomena
and for every organ in your body whether
or not that's your heart
or your lungs or your spleen both
the mechanical information about that
organ
for instance is if your gut is full
or empty whether or not your heart is
beating fast or beating slowly that's
mechanical
and chemical information whether or not
your gut feels nice and whether you know
when i say nice i mean whether or not it
has a balance of acidity and
alkalinity that feels right to you or
whether or not your gut feels off
it doesn't feel quite right that's
chemical information
if you are not getting enough oxygen and
levels of carbon dioxide another gas go
up too high so your
lungs can register that and that
chemical information
is sent to your brain and then your
brain does certain things actually it
really encourages you to do certain
things in order to adjust that chemistry
so the first principle that everyone
should understand about their sense of
self
is that they are sensing mechanical and
chemical information about every organ
in their body
except for one and that's the brain your
brain actually doesn't
have pain receptors it doesn't even have
touch receptors
the brain is a command center it helps
drive and govern changes in the organs
of the body but your brain doesn't move
at least not much it can move a little
bit
fluid moves within it but as long as
you're healthy it's not moving that much
your brain has no sensation of its own
in fact when they do brain surgery on
people
they will anesthetize or put some
anesthesia on the scalp they'll cut away
the skin there so
that people don't feel anything they'll
use some anesthesia they'll peel back
the skin
and then they'll use a well let's call
it what it is it's a bone
saw and they basically saw open a little
window
in the skull i've actually done this
before and seen this before i've done
this many times before
and once you're inside the brain you can
put electrodes in there and you can
put various things in there of course
all for therapeutic purposes
and you do that without any anesthesia
to the actual brain tissue because it
has no
receptors to sense anything it doesn't
have pain receptors it doesn't have
pressure receptors none of that
when you have a headache and your head
feels like it's just too much pressure
well that's because of receptors that
lie outside the brain
so your organs are different they need
to tell your brain what's going on
and there are ways that you can control
the mechanical and the chemical state
of your organs in ways that are very
powerful
and this is crucial to do because if you
can properly regulate
the mechanical and chemical environment
of your body
your brain functions better this is
absolutely clear from data that if your
gut is healthy if you get the alkalinity
right the acidity right
and if your spleen is healthy and happy
and if your lungs are working properly
not just breathing and pumping in and
out air but you're breathing at the
right cadence for a particular activity
then your brain will function better so
let's talk about how you can adjust the
mechanical and chemical environment
of your organs in order to make your
brain better and how your brain can
make the mechanical and chemical
environment within your organs function
better
for instance we're going to talk about
how you can change the chemistry of your
gut
in order for your brain to be able to
focus better think better remember
better
and sleep better and we're going to talk
about how you can change
the chemistry of other organs in your
body such that your immune system will
function better than it would otherwise
and you can actually heal faster
from small cuts and bruises but also
injuries of any kind even
major injuries so as i mentioned before
we've got these organs the heart the
lungs the diaphragm and i'll explain
what that is
the gut and the spleen and the spleen is
this immune organ
let's take one example of these and
explain how mechanical and chemical
information
from this particular set of organs
communicates to the brain and how that
changes how our brain works
and the organ i'd like to focus on first
are the
lungs and the diaphragm so we're all
familiar with our lungs these two big
bags of air but they're actually not too
big bags of air they actually have
little tiny sacks within them actually
millions of little sacks
called the avioli of the lungs there we
go the lungs are like little tiny
balloons
throughout our lungs and the more of
those balloons we have the more air that
we can actually contain so we are not
too big
uh bags of air in there our lungs we
actually have
millions and millions of little tiny
bags of air within those lungs
those little bags of air can fill up or
they can deflate
right just like your lungs overall can
fill up or they can deflate
the diaphragm is a muscle it's kind of
shaped like a dome
so it's kind of a you know think about a
basketball
or a soccer ball that has most of the
air pushed out of it
and so it's kind of crescent shape or
dome shaped and it sits below our lungs
and the way the diaphragm and the lungs
work together is very interesting
the diaphragm is actually skeletal
muscle so it's just like a bicep or a
quadricep
and the fact that it is skeletal muscle
is important because it
has a unique property which is that you
can control it voluntarily you can
decide to take control of your diaphragm
by just consciously deciding you want to
breathe in a particular way
just like you can take conscious control
over your legs they will work just fine
if you're not thinking about them as you
walk as provided you already know how to
walk
but at any moment you can decide to
change the rate of your walking your
so-called cadence of walking
so the diaphragm as a skeletal muscle
also has that property
the diaphragm moves up and down
depending on how you breathe
or rather i should say how the diaphragm
moves up and down
determines how you breathe how you
breathe is also dependent on little
muscles that are between your ribs
uh the intercostals and other muscles if
you're a martial arts fan
bruce lee was famous for having these
very pronounced intercostals
um from doing all sorts of you know
bridging exercise etc but if
those are the muscles and we all have
them even if some uh some of us most of
us
uh don't have um intercostals like bruce
lee
so when you breathe a couple things
happen but let's talk about the
mechanical things
first and then let's talk about how
those mechanical steps
relate back to the brain and what that
does for the brain
and i can promise you that if you
develop an awareness of these mechanical
changes
you do not have to go through extensive
breath work
practice or do extensive breath work you
will immediately
believe it or not develop a sense of
your breathing self of your lungs and
diaphragm it takes no practice but once
you do it
you will forever be changed in terms of
your awareness of your breathing and
your ability
to leverage your breathing kind of like
the steering wheel on a car in order to
shift your brain
in the direction that you want to go so
it's a very powerful system
and the way it works is the following
and this will also
incorporate the heart so and by the
heart i don't mean it in the emotional
sense although we we don't rule out
emotions here at the hubermann lab
podcast we like emotions
but i'm talking about the heart as an
organ as a beating organ that circulates
blood
so when we inhale these little sacs in
our lungs fill up
and our lungs expand and when we do that
we take up space
in our thoracic cavity and our diaphragm
moves down okay when we exhale the
diaphragm moves
up the lungs get smaller okay so
inhale's diaphragm moves down
exhales diaphragm moves up this actually
controls
our heart rate but it does it by
changing the way that our brain works
and it works in the following way
so when we inhale our lungs fill our
diaphragm moves down
our heart actually has a little more
space because the diaphragms move down
so the heart gets a little bit bigger
physically bigger not in the emotional
sense but
physically bigger and as a consequence
whatever blood is in the heart
flows at a slower rate because it's a
larger volume so bigger volume heart
same amount of of blood inside the heart
means slower flow
okay sort of like expanding a pipe the
brain registers that because there are a
set of neurons on the heart called the
sinoatrial node
it sends that information to the brain
that information is registered by the
brain and the brain sends a message back
to the heart
to speed the heart up so every time you
inhale
because of these mechanical changes in
the diaphragm and lungs
and because of the mechanical changes in
the heart
your brain sends a signal to the heart
to speed the heart up
so if you do long inhales or you inhale
more vigorously
you actually are speeding your heart up
now of course you have to exhale as well
but for instance if i were to inhale
very long like
the entire time my heart rate is
increasing and then if i did a quick
exhale
something else will happen but if i kept
doing that
my heart rate would increase it's not
going to increase linearly and forever
but it will increase
with each inhale or i can simply make my
inhales more vigorous
and my heart rate will speed up this is
an autonomic and automatic
relationship between the diaphragm the
lungs
the brain and the heart now if inhales
speed the heart up what happens on
exhales when we exhale
the diaphragm moves up it's a little
counterintuitive but you kind of think
you can kind of think about it as like
pushing the plunge on a syringe right
when you
exhale this thing moves up and
as the diaphragm moves up the heart has
less space
meaning it gets a little bit smaller
which means that whatever volume of
blood is inside the heart
moves faster through that smaller volume
that information is sent to the brain
via these collection of neurons called
the sinoatrial node
for you aficionados the brain then sends
information
via the vagus nerve back to the heart
to slow the heart down so while
inhales speed up the heart that's the
net effect
exhales slow the heart down and the
reason they slow the heart down is
because of
a register in the change in mechanical
pressure
between the diaphragm the lungs and the
heart so this is
to me the simplest and most
straightforward example
of how the brain is changing the way our
organs work
our heart in this case according to
changes in mechanical interoception
now we're not always aware of this some
of us are aware of it some of us
aren't if you do it right now you will
be aware of it so you can try this
you can basically this is an experiment
or an example
in interoception in sensing one's self
so if you inhale doesn't matter how long
you inhale i'll do it for a couple
seconds
and then exhale twice as long
nose or mouth doesn't matter the entire
time that you're exhaling you're slowing
your heart down
so just as a car has an accelerator and
a break or you can slow a
car by coming off the accelerator when
you exhale you're effectively coming off
the accelerator or
if you want to think about it
differently you're hitting the brake
you're slowing down your heart rate
now normally your heart rate stays in
more or less the same
range for a given activity because
you're inhaling and exhaling
but this is just a simple way of showing
that mechanical changes in your viscera
can change the way that your brain works
and then your brain changes the way that
those viscera work
and it's a very concrete agreement it's
like a contract between the organs of
your body and the brain
in fact you can think about this
contract in more detail and you can
leverage this in a very powerful way to
set the conditions of your mind
if you want to be more calm emphasize
exhales and the simplest way to do this
i've talked about this many times before
but if you haven't heard me say it
this will become immediately clear is to
emphasize exhales
through what's called a physiological
sigh
two inhales could be through the nose or
the mouth but ideally through the nose
so
followed by a long exhale
those double inhales are kind of
important because what they do is they
maximally fill all those little sacks in
your lungs
and then when you breathe out you're
exhaling as
much of the so-called carbon dioxide in
your system as possible we'll talk about
carbon dioxide in a second
so the fastest way to calm down is to
emphasize
exhales when you make exhales longer
you're slowing your heart rate you're
calming down
you don't need any sophisticated
training you don't have to do this for
minutes on end
you don't have to do anything you don't
even have to call it breath work it's
just respiration
and in fact you do this every night when
you go to sleep and carbon dioxide
builds up too much in your bloodstream
or if you hold your breath or something
or if you watch an animal or a small
child
that's sleeping they will occasionally
do these double inhale long exhales it's
a way of slowing the heart down
and eliminating carbon dioxide the
opposite is also true
if you inhale deeply or vigorously
and then exhale less long or less
vigorously
you will increase your level of
alertness through these purely
mechanical
aspects of your interoception so for
instance if i were to take a big deep
inhale
and then a short exhale and then another
one
big inhale short exhale it only takes
two or three of those before you start
to feel
more alert and that's because your heart
rate is increasing and actually if you
keep doing that for 25 or 30 breaths
of inhale deep short exhale you will
start to secrete
a lot of adrenaline this hormone that
comes from your kidneys and from your
brain stem
make you feel really alert you will
actually feel as if you've had a couple
espresso
you will immediately wake up and
there's an intermediate form of
breathing which is sometimes called box
breathing but it's really equal inhale
and exhale duration
and these it basically goes like this
you're going to inhale so do this for
maybe two three seconds inhale
then hold two three seconds then exhale
two three seconds then hold
two three seconds most often people
forget to hold so it's inhale
hold exhale hold for equal or more or
less equal duration so it could be one
second could be two seconds could be
three seconds
most people find that when you get out
past five seconds they start to struggle
to maintain the so-called box breathing
and most people can't
consciously box breathe for too terribly
long without having to think about it
but the point here is that through
purely mechanical means
changing the way that you breathe
emphasizing inhales or exhales or
keeping them the same will change the
way that your brain works
how alert you are and how well you
function in anything and again
this doesn't mean that breath work has
no value it's just simply to say that
long extended protocols of breath work
are simply
they are truly simply just an
exploration of this fundamental
relationship between the mechanics
of your internal organs and your brain
and how
your brain controls those internal
organs now
you might ask well how is this pressure
known how does the body actually know
how full the lungs are now this is a
an answer that's more for the
aficionados out there but i've had a few
requests or i should say thousands of
requests
for more in-depth science so if you're
not interested in more in-depth science
um
just this will allow you to tune out now
for maybe just 10 seconds and if you are
interested
pay careful attention there is a set of
receptors
which are called piezo receptors
p-i-e-z-o
piezo receptors piezo means pressure
and these were discovered a few years
ago by a couple different laboratories
but one of the main ones one of the main
laboratories that discovered these piezo
receptors
is the laboratory of ardem parapuccin i
love saying his name even though i'm
probably mispronouncing it he's a
friend and a former colleague when my
lab was down in san diego he's at the
scripps institute
he's a howard hughes medical institute
investigator which just says
which just basically means that he's a
total stud of science and has made many
important discoveries
the piezo receptors line many tissues
and inform the brain about pressure in
those tissues but the lungs have a
particular category of piezo receptors
called piezo2 receptors and as you fill
your lungs
and these little sacks of air the
eviolet fill
the piezo2 receptors because of the way
they react to that
filling send information by way of a
bunch of neurons a bunch of wires up to
the brain and tell you how full your
lungs are
so that's the kind of mechanistic detail
if you want to learn more about that you
can
look up our dems lab at the scripts
and the beautiful work that they and
other laboratories are doing on piezos
piezos are pretty cool i think i also
just like saying piezo
so that's why i brought that up as well
so mechanical
sensing of the lungs heart and diaphragm
and now let's talk about chemical
sensing because there's carbon dioxide
and there's oxygen and this is
really simple you have oxygen and carbon
dioxide
and you need them both i sometimes hear
people talk about carbon dioxide as this
bad thing
and oxygen is a good thing you need them
both and you need them in the
appropriate balance
you have a collection of neurons in your
brain that register when carbon dioxide
levels
get to a certain point in your
bloodstream
when that point that threshold is
reached these neurons fire
and they cause you to breathe it's
sometimes called the gasp reflex
it just makes you want to inhale and as
a consequence you bring in
more oxygen okay so we don't really
breathe to get oxygen
that's a byproduct of inhaling to
eliminate carbon dioxide you don't want
carbon dioxide levels to go too high
in fact if you want to freak somebody
out and we do these in experiments and i
don't recommend you do this
you just increase the levels of carbon
dioxide that they inhale
and the brain will go into an almost
immediate panic response
because the health of all our tissues
depends on keeping a nice balance
between carbon dioxide and oxygen you
don't want carbon dioxide levels to go
too high
so the impulse to breathe if you're
under water
or if you hold your breath is triggered
by these neurons
and the triggering of those neurons
comes from
elevated carbon dioxide in the
bloodstream and for those of you that
don't
quite know how to conceptualize the
relationship between bloodstream and
breath
i do think it's important maybe you
remember this from high school biology
but if you don't
i'll make it clear for you now it's very
easy you inhale air
and that air and the oxygen molecules in
that air
actually move from your lungs into the
bloodstream because these little avioli
of the lungs
those little sacks of air are in they
basically have
a lot of little micro vessels and
capillaries
little tiny basically blood vessels
essentially although they're mostly
capillaries micro capillaries the little
tiny ones
that line them so there's actually an
interface an opportunity for
air to and molecules within the air to
pass
into the blood and then they move in
your bloodstream and when you exhale
the opposite is true so you can move
things from the air
into your bloodstream or from your
bloodstream into the air by way of the
lungs
and there's a lot more detail to it and
i'm sure those of you there are experts
out there if you want to put some stuff
in the comments
maybe a little bit of a kind of
intermediate tutorial you might even
title it intermediate tutorial if you
know a lot about this just
i'll check it but make sure you get the
details right make sure you you know the
process
and i find that for people that are
interested in understanding how
breathing really works
it's really nice to think about the
relationship between the heart and the
vascular system the blood and the
air system the respiration system and
breathing because those two things are
very we say they're interdigitated
they're interwoven with one another
so how's this work well carbon dioxide
is too high
you breathe in you inspire you inhale
you off
as a consequence when you exhale you
offload carbon dioxide
there's a really cool way that you can
explore this chemistry of your breathing
and your bloodstream and the way that
your brain works in ways that can really
benefit your health
and it works the following way you want
to essentially
sit or lie down it doesn't really matter
you definitely don't want to be anywhere
near water not a bathtub not a hot tub
not a
you know not a cold dunk or something in
fact don't even be in a puddle
and what you want to do in this case is
you're going to breathe in deep so
that's going to increase your heart rate
and then
exhale passively by just letting air
fall out of your mouth so it would look
something like this
so let's say you breathe in vigorously
and then you let the air just fall
out of your mouth when you do that
what you're essentially doing is you're
bringing in a lot of oxygen through that
deep breath
and you're exhaling a little bit of that
carbon dioxide
but if you were to repeat it 25 times
maybe 30 times
doesn't matter if it's 25 or 30
somewhere in there
you would essentially start bringing in
a lot of oxygen and
blowing off or exhaling a lot of carbon
dioxide
so you're actually going to change the
chemistry of your internal landscape
and you can then sense it you can
interocept
what that is like and there are some
really interesting reasons for wanting
to do that
so i'm not going to do all 25 or 30 now
maybe do 5 or 10 so you can get a sense
of what it looks like
so that it's clear i'm going to
essentially demonstrate now so it's
inhale
exhale through the mouth i am inhaling
through the nose
so it's essentially excuse me a two
two second or so inhale and then a one
second or so exhale and as i was doing
that i can kind of feel my face get
flush
and my body is heating up and my brain
is heating up what's happening there
well
that pattern of breathing is increasing
levels of adrenaline
in my brain and body and i'm getting
more alert
then after 25 or 30 of those you exhale
all your air you dump all your air
you can do that your nose or your mouth
and then you hold your breath
with your lungs empty for about 15 to 30
seconds
now for those of you that want to
explore this and please be careful as
you explore this don't do anything
stupid like do this while you're driving
or
something like that you can exhale all
your air
and what you'll find then is you can
hold your breath for a very
long time and the reason you can do that
is because
you've blown off all the carbon dioxide
or most of the carbon dioxide in your
bloodstream so you've shifted the
chemistry
of your blood by breathing in a
particular way
and by doing that you are no longer
triggering these neurons
that cause the gasp reflex or the reflex
to breathe
now of course you have to breathe sooner
or later but what you'll find is if
normally your
ability to hold your breath is a minute
or so before you
really feel that gasp reflex kicking you
might
find that you can go 90 seconds or two
minutes and with some practice people
find that they can start holding their
breath for three or four minutes or
longer this is actually how free divers
do what they do i do not
want anyone free diving if you're going
to learn free diving pre please learn it
from an
expert many people die trying to teach
themselves out of free dive or trying to
teach their friends out of free dive
when they don't know what they're doing
this is not what this is about don't
again don't do this anywhere near water
but it is
a very interesting exploration of how
you can shift the chemistry of your
bloodstream
by modulating your air by modulating the
mechanics
of your diaphragm and lungs and thereby
shift the way
your mind works your brain in fact what
you'll notice
is that even though during that 25 or 30
breaths
you'll feel very alert when you exhale
all your air and you're in the breath
hold you will feel very alert but
very very calm now this is interesting
because it's a state that we all sort of
want to achieve alert but calm but have
a hard time achieving
and so for those of you that have a hard
time obtaining focus for sake of work
or focus for sake of anything i should
say and
when you are able to achieve focus it's
through the use of things like
stimulants or you feel like you have to
have a cold shower or ice bath or you
have to have four espresso in order to
be alert
but then you're too alert you're jittery
you can't focus
this pattern of breathing can lend
itself very well to entering states of
alert but calm for the follow the 10 or
even 20 minutes that follow that
breathing
and then you could repeat it if you want
so it's a very useful practice to
explore
some of you may be familiar with this
practice a so-called wim hof breathing
wim hof is a practitioner of what's
called
tumor breathing tumor breathing has been
around for centuries and for those of
you
that are familiar with breath work and
yogurt practices
i acknowledge that nothing i just
described is new
based on science however the science
informs why those practices
work and just as a little mini editorial
i just want to emphasize as well that
one thing that this podcast is really
about is trying to remove
fancy nomenclature whether or not it's
yogic nomenclature or scientific
nomenclature so that people can access
protocols because
the moment we start naming things after
people or
calling them tumor etc i have no problem
with that but it doesn't inform how the
practices are done
nor does it inform the underlying
mechanisms so here i'm trying to teach
you
the mechanisms and as a final point to
that
the most powerful form of breathing is
the one that takes into account the
fundamental mechanisms that inhales
increase heart rate
that exhales decrease heart rate and
that carbon dioxide and oxygen relate to
the bloodstream and the brain in
particular ways once you understand
those components then you can create
your own so-called breath work practices
you can breathe in the ways that best
serve you as opposed to thinking that
one protocol
is the best or holy protocol for
everything because it's simply not
as a final final point i want to say
that as you shift
the way that you breathe whether or not
you're blowing off more carbon dioxide
or bringing in more oxygen you are
fundamentally changing the chemistry of
your internal milieu of your body
and that has been shown to have
important effects on the way that your
immune system functions and the way that
you deal with inflammation
and all sorts of different sort of uh
things that can enter your body and
cause problems or
conditions of stress etc so i will
explore that further as the episode goes
on
but i want to move on to just touch on
one other aspect
of breathing that's purely mechanical
which i think is very interesting and
important
which relates to a particular reflex
that you're going to be very familiar
with in a second
and that can serve you very well in
times of extreme stress
the reflex i'm referring to is something
called the herring brewer reflex
i'm not going to go into details about
how the herring brewer reflex works but
it has to do
with particular classes of neurons and
cells that are called
baroreceptors those are basically
pressure receptors they sense pressure
and basically what the herringbrewer
reflex is about
is that when your lung is inflated your
desire to breathe
is reduced so you can try that right now
you can inhale
huge book big beard
and hold okay your desire to breathe
will
kick in later than were you to exhale
all your air
and hold your breath when you exhale all
your air and hold your breath unless
you've done the sort of protocol i
described a few minutes ago of doing a
bunch of inhales and exhales first in a
very deliberate way
you will feel empty those baroreceptors
are going to be firing like crazy saying
there's no pressure in here there's no
pressure here i got nothing in here
you need to breathe you need to breathe
in the gas reflex will kick in sooner
you can apply that in all sorts of
situations related to
exercise related to modulating stress
etc so the herring brewer reflex
is a very powerful one this is why you
take a big deep breath before you go
under water
right you're not going to exhale all
your air and go under water if you were
to exhale all your air and go underwater
you would absolutely feel the need to
come up sooner for a breath of air than
had you
a full tank so to speak a full
of lungs full of air and this is also
the way that people teach themselves to
feel comfortable under underwater so
when you learn how to swim you learn how
to swim both by having air in your lungs
while you're underwater and
no air in your lungs while you're
underwater in any event the herring
brewer reflex is
yet another dimension to the way that
mechanical pressure
influences your brain's decision making
about what to do with your body in this
case whether or not to breathe
so now i want to shift away from
breathing and diaphragm and lungs and
move
toward another organ within our viscera
which is
our gut so this includes our stomach and
our intestines our esophagus and so
forth
it's been said before both by me and by
others that we are but a series of
tubes and indeed that's true believe it
or not every system in your body
is a tube your brain is actually a tube
that connects to your spinal cord which
is also a tube you started off as a tube
you were like a churro you know those
like churros i don't know if you're not
familiar with churros they're like
donuts that are shaped like a tube
that's essentially what you look like
early in development not long after
conception
and the front end of that churro grew
and grew and grew but
you always maintained a hollow through
that tube that's why you have what are
called
ventricles gaps or a space in your brain
and spinal cord that run the length of
your brain and spinal cord and fluid
cerebral spinal fluid and other things
move through that space we're going to
return to the ventricles later they are
very very important they're just space
filled with fluid
but they do a lot similarly
your digestive system starts with the
tube at your mouth
and of course goes down through your
throat and then you've got all the
elements of the stomach and the
intestines
and then it comes out the other end so
you are but a series of different tubes
your vascular system a series of other
tubes so your
tubes the way your digestive system
works is to communicate to your brain
about the status of the mechanical
pressures
along this tube so within your stomach
and your intestines etc
and the chemical status of that tube
at various portions within that tube
to inform your brain about how your
brain
should control that tube so let's start
with the mechanical
sensing of your gut if you drink a lot
of fluid
or if you eat a lot of food your gut
will fill up your stomach will fill up
with food
now it gets digested there it gets
digested elsewhere along your digestive
tract too of course
but it starts getting digested there
because along this tube
you have a series of what are called
sphincters which basically are like
little
draw poles have you ever had a laundry
bag which has a drawstring on it you
pull it and then it cinches shut and
then you can open it again
that's what those are those are
sphincter openings and
you have them in your throat you have
them along your digestive tract
all the way to the end
will enter your gut and if there's a lot
of that food
pressure receptors some of which are
these piezo receptors
will communicate communicate to the
areas of your brain that are involved in
feeding and will say don't eat anymore
you don't need to consume anymore now
some people bypass
that these uh i guess they have these
like hot dog eating competitions
i'm always struck by how some of those
people are like seem to be rail thin
but they actually train for those
competitions
by ingesting large volumes of water
actually a very dangerous practice you
can actually kill yourself by drinking
too much water
and you can kill yourself by ingesting
too much of anything really to expand
your gut
not a good practice not a big fan of
those competitions but even if
you're one of those people or you're the
world heavyweight champion of them they
are informative toward what i'm talking
about now which is that
as you expand the gut a signal is sent
by
neurons literally nerve cells that are
in the gut
to the brain stem up to the areas of the
brain that are involved in feeding i did
a whole episode on feeding
you can find on feeding metabolism and
hunger you're welcome to
listen to that episode if you like and
it will shut down the neurons that drive
the desire to put more stuff
in your mouth that thing that people say
sometimes on well in this country
frequently after thanksgiving meal i
can't put another bite in my mouth
literally they shut down some of the
basic movements of the musculature to
take another fork bite
i know it sounds crazy but they can
actually control your brain so your gut
is so full that it's controlling your
brain such that this
action of spooning food towards your
mouth is actually inhibited
it's made more difficult or less likely
to occur
it's incredible the converse is also
true when these piezo receptors signal
to the brain that the gut is empty
independent of your need your actual
need for food there's a signal that's
sent to your brain
that says gut is empty and neurons get
stimulated in areas like the arcuate
nucleus and these areas of the
hypothalamus etc
that drive the desire to make this
action to open the mouth
and to put stuff in it in particular
food
so when you find yourself at the
refrigerator or you find yourself
almost you know manically trying to get
food of different kinds you're not even
thinking about what you're eating
because you're so hungry
in part that's because the lack of food
in your gut has
sent that information to your brain and
is driving particular
fixed action patterns that are
associated with eating in fact one of
the first things children learn how to
do is open their mouth
when something is presented to it and
then they learn how to move a spoon or a
fork
they're not very good at first they get
all over the place but eventually they
get good at least most people get good
at if you watch how people eat
you know it's kind of very variable out
there
in any event this is a purely mechanical
phenomenon
and this purely mechanical phenomenon is
driving our brain to drive certain
behavior
you can get better at registering sense
of fullness
or lack of fullness in a very particular
way
some people have a very keen sense of
how full or empty their stomach is
so if you've eaten anything even if it's
a small volume of food in the last
hour to three hours it's actually a
worthwhile practice to take a few
moments maybe
10 20 seconds and actually just try and
concentrate on sensing
the neurons in your gut and how full you
are like for instance i ate a few hours
ago
then i had a little snack about 30
minutes ago
or so and my gut feels neither terribly
full
nor terribly empty it's kind of i would
put it kind of like 30 40
okay so by just
taking conscious awareness of how full
or empty our gut is at various
times between meals after a meal
before a meal you can very quickly
develop a sense of how full or empty you
are now what's the consequence of that
the consequence of that is actually
rather interesting it's been shown that
the consequence
of that is actually that you can better
override the signals of these piezo
receptors
and gut fullness or emptiness so for
those of you that find that you eat kind
of uh compulsively or
non-consciously or subconsciously i
should say you probably have to be
conscious enough to be awake to eat but
subconsciously you just find yourself
eating and here i'm describing myself
i'm like i'm a drive-by blueberry eater
if there's a bowl of blueberries
every time i walk past it i sort of have
to grab a handful of them and pop them
in my mouth
but if you develop this sense of how
much mechanopressure
it's not really a word but how much
mechanosensation is in your gut
very quickly you can learn to override
that you might ask why would i want to
be able to override
whether or not my stomach is empty or my
stomach is full well
there are many reasons to want to do
that many people right now are
interested in so-called intermittent
fasting they're doing fasts of anywhere
from 12 to 16 hours every 24-hour cycle
that's actually what my practice is i do
that on a regular basis sometimes yeah i
eat breakfast but normally i push
breakfast out to about 11 or noon or
sometimes a little later
some people are doing longer fast and
there are really wonderful data
published in
excellent journals from my colleague
sachin panda
at the salk institute of biological
studies and of course from other
laboratories
showing that intermittent fasting can
and will have some positive health
effects
on things like liver health and brain
health and other aspects of health
whether or not it's the best form of
dieting for the sake of losing weight
that's very controversial
but it's clear that having a period of
fasting
every 24 hours or perhaps even longer
from time to time
can be beneficial because it stimulates
what's called autophagy
the clearing away or the the body's
ability to eat
certain dead cells so called senescent
cells and for many people they struggle
with fasting because they feel they have
a very keen sense of their stomach
being empty and they feel as if they
have to eat
and in a kind of counter-intuitive way
there's some data that indicate that
being able to sense whether or not your
gut is full or empty
and just the knowledge that that's
communicating information to your brain
about whether to not to eat or not
just that awareness that understanding
allows them to override the signal they
think oh you know i'm not
actually in need of nutrients right now
it's just that my stomach is empty
and these piezo receptors and some other
ones that i'll tell you about in
a moment are signaling to my brain that
it's empty i don't actually need
food it's just pain it's just that my
brain is reacting to the fact that my
gut
is deflated so to speak or is smaller
doesn't have food in it
so there are other ways that our guts
communicate with our brain it's not just
our stomach talking to our brain
it's also our intestines talk to our
brain
the lieberly's lab the guy's name is
stephen lieberly's he runs a lab at
harvard medical school's terrific lab
does excellent work on gut brain
communication and other aspects of
viscera brain communication they
discovered a category of neurons
called the glp1r neurons these are
neurons
that are basically in in your neck i
mean they're part of the nervous system
but they're you can they can be found
near your neck
and those neurons send little wires down
into
the intestines and deep into the stomach
but mostly into the intestines and they
sense
stretch of your intestines so this is
pretty wild these neurons sense how
stretched out your intestines are and
how fast things are moving through your
intestines
slow or fast or if there's nothing there
and then those neurons
send another branch so they have a
branch in one direction senses
what's going on in your intestines and
they have another branch that goes up
from your neck
into your brain to either trigger the
desire to eat more or to stop eating
these are really really cool neurons and
they're basically stretch receptors they
look a lot like the piezo receptors that
we talked about before
so these glp-1 r neurons are sensing
stretch so purely mechanical sensing
and in addition to that the lieberly's
lab discovered
neurons that detect nutrients themselves
now the main reason why we need to eat
is to bring
nutrients into our body and there
is another set of neurons those are
called gpr65 neurons if you want to know
that you don't have to remember that
that do the same thing in terms of their
connections they send connections down
into the intestines and into the gut
into the stomach but mostly into the
intestines and then send that
information back up to the brain as to
whether or not
there are certain kinds of nutrients in
our digestive tract
now these neurons are the ones to pay
attention to if we're talking about
chemical signaling and then in the next
couple of minutes i'm going to tell you
about
how you can understand hunger and how to
modulate your hunger
for the right foods in fact for healthy
foods
the way this is done is by leveraging
the activity of these gpr-65 neurons
these neurons that
sense nutrients okay they're telling
your brain
what's in your gut and intestines and
you have another set of neurons that
were discovered by another guy
he's out at duke university his name is
diego excuse me diego diego borges
he's a wonderful scientist he has a
degree in nutrition
but also in neuroscience and he found
that there are neurons that
line the gut and those neurons in
collaboration with these gpr65 neurons
are sensing for three things
okay so we say nutrients which nutrients
are they looking for what are these
neurons paying attention to
well these neurons are activated by the
presence of
fatty acids in particular omega-3 fatty
acids
sorts of things that come from fatty
fish fish oil krill
certain kinds of animal prote animal and
plant
substances you can look up what has a
lot of omega-3s
and those omega-3s make these neurons
fire electrically like crazy up to the
brain
and make you want to eat more of those
things but it turns out in pretty
appropriate levels
these neurons also respond to amino
acids
so when you eat a food it's broken down
in the gut actually the way it's broken
down the gut is kind of interesting
your gut basically cinches off a
sphincter up top
cinches off a sphincter below it when
there's food there
and then you have a series of smooth
muscles that
tumble the food and literally physically
break it down and then of course
enzymes come in and start digesting the
food and we're going to talk about
digestion and how that's communicated to
the brain in a moment
and for those of you with any autoimmune
issues or digestive issues
this can be very important conversation
but meanwhile
there are these neurons in the gut and
as these fatty acids float out of the
digestive food so literally
fat molecules and as amino acids
are coming from the proteins as they're
digested in the gut
and as a third food item sugars are
coming from
the foods that we eat these neurons will
fire a lot to the brain that says
hey whatever you're doing up there do
more of it okay
now the sugars are a little bit cryptic
because when i say
sugars or i say amino acids or i say
fatty acids this has nothing to do with
taste
in fact beautiful experiments have been
done by the borges lab and by other labs
showing
that even if you numb the mouth even if
you gavage which is a really just a it's
a fancy word
for basically tube feeding you put a
tube down in the gut you just deliver
the food to the gut so you get no
opportunity to taste it
sounds pretty awful if you force feed by
gavage
or you numb the mouth these neurons
don't care about the mouth
they only care about the nutrients
coming from these foods and then they
signal to the brain
hey do that thing do that thing where
you lift that
object we call a fork or a spoon do that
thing where you drink the milkshake do
that thing where you move your mouth
like this
not talking but do that thing where you
swallow so that's
how the nutrients in our gut control us
and this is why for people that
experience extreme sugar cravings or
even mild sugar cravings
replacing those foods with foods that
have high levels of omega-3
or amino acids can reduce sugar cravings
and i've talked about this
on a previous episode but if you didn't
catch it no big deal i'll tell you right
now
that for many people the solution to
sugar cravings is to ingest a small
amount maybe a teaspoon or so of an
amino acid called
glutamine and if you have really extreme
sugar cravings you can even mix that
glutamine with
a full fat cream which actually makes it
taste pretty darn good
and you drink that anytime you have a
sugar craving or just a sip or two of
that and what you find is that the sugar
cravings disappear because you're
basically giving fat and
amino acids to those neurons in the gut
and in the intestine
that signal to the brain that you want
more now this doesn't give you a kind of
runaway hunger for
for full fat cream although i will say
when i was in high school
for um various reasons but mostly
because i like the way it tastes i
i was using half and half in my cereal
and i was waking up in the middle night
and drinking half and half and that
stuff tastes pretty darn good once you
get used to the high fat content
not something i do now but the point is
these neurons don't really know taste
they only know nutrients and so you can
work with that system if you're if you
crave sugar and i do believe that
most if not all of us should be trying
to limit if not eliminate
simple sugars as much as possible most
of the time
then things like glutamine things like
high omega-3 foods etc maybe even want
to supplement with fish oil
or something similar to get omega-3s
there are other reasons for wanting to
do that too
can be very beneficial and here's what
we're talking about
is interoception it's your ability to
sense your inner real estate
but in this case by way of chemical
signaling not by way of mechanical
signaling
so now i'd like to talk about another
aspect of gut chemistry
that has profound effects on the brain
as well as on the immune system
and for those of you with autoimmune
conditions or for those of you that
know people with autoimmune conditions
this is going to be a very important
discussion
your gut needs to maintain a certain
level of acidity
or alkalinity for those of you without
any chemistry background
basically the low numbers on the ph
scale that means more acidic
the higher the numbers more alkaline so
more alkaline means more basic
and acidic means acidic and it has to do
with
number of hydrogen atoms and all this
other stuff but you don't need to worry
about that right now
we're not going to ph your gut right now
but we are going to talk about the ph of
your gut
your gut needs to be more acidic than
essentially all other tissues of your
body in order to function properly
bacteria thrive in alkaline conditions
i think this is important for people to
understand people are always thinking oh
you should be more
alkaline being acidic that almost sounds
like uh
being inflamed well you know it's a
complicated discussion but
i think the semantics can be confusing
sometimes you want your gut to be acidic
you may ask well why are people taking
anti-acids
well those anti-acids are there for a
particular purpose to
essentially combat acid reflux which is
descending up of stuff in the gut
towards the esophagus and it can cause
heartburn and things of that sort
and the way that anti-acids work
is they essentially cause the sphincters
above the gut to cinch
shut but they really are only dealing
with a symptom not the cause
so rewind about 10 20 years ago the
discussion about gut acidity
was quite a bit different than it is now
in the scientific and medical literature
in fact for many years long before
i'm going to say it here people have
been saying that
it's important to maintain proper
acidity of the gut
but the science and medical professions
sort of looked at that as
a kind of a scance like you know what's
going on there i don't know that there's
any evidence that that's actually true
there are communities of people that
were prescribing or i should say
recommending that people take
hydrochloric acid
hcl and adjusting gut acidity that way
and it was kind of frowned upon now in
looking over the peer-reviewed
literature it's clear
that this business of trying to make the
gut a little more acidic is actually one
way in which people
treat or try and ameliorate
acid reflux so it's kind of
counterintuitive increasing acidity in
the gut to try and reduce
acid reflux i thought you're supposed to
take anti-acids well
the field has shifted quite a bit and so
we're going to review what it is
to maintain the chemistry of the gut at
a
slightly more acidic level or a more
acidic level i should say because it
turns out
that there are a number of things that
are in gut i just call it what it is
it's gastric juice
sounds kind of gross but gastric juices
are actually
powerful modulators of brain state
put differently one of the best things
that you can do to have a healthy brain
a well-functioning brain and a healthy
and well-functioning body
is to maintain proper gut chemistry
and that's basically accomplished by
getting the right level of acidity and
alkalinity
in your gut now this is not quack
pseudoscience this is not based on
cleanses or anything of that sort
what we're going to talk about now are
peer-reviewed data
in very high quality journals like the
journal cell
which is one of the three apex journals
science nature cell
and journals of that sort that point to
the gut microbiome and its relationship
to acidity of the gut
and how the gut microbiome can help
enhance
autoimmune function and various other
aspects of brain and body health
so within all the mucosal line tissues
of our body
we have what are called microbiota
little microorganisms that we didn't
make that actually come from our
environment
or our food and live inside us
and there are good microbiota and there
are bad microbiota
whether or not we have good microbiota
or bad microbiota depends on
one thing and that one thing is how acid
or alkaline the given mucosal tissue
is so we actually have a microbiome in
our nose
and just as a very brief aside because
i'd be remiss if i didn't say this
if you emphasize nasal breathing most of
the time except when speaking or eating
and if you downplay mouth breathing
meaning you refrain from mouth breathing
especially in
sleep you improve
the nasal microbiome it gets better
at fighting off infections this was
shown in a beautiful paper published in
cell reports last year
and that paper i should mention was
performed in humans
so you've got a microbiome in your nose
and by nasal breathing most of the time
not all the time because there can be
times when you need to breathe through
your mouth for whatever reason hard
exercise or you know eating or speaking
but by breathing through your nose most
of the time you are creating an
additional
layer of immune defense against
particles that could get you sick
whereas when you mouth breathe you are
taking down a layer of defense and you
are putting yourself more at risk of
infection this is what this paper shows
you also have a gut microbiome that is
in your throat in your stomach
and in your intestines and that gut
microbiome is extremely powerful in
regulating your mood
and your immune function now this is not
something that you can
sense directly you don't know when you
have a bunch of good microbiota
or a bunch of bad microbiota because you
can feel them moving around in there
actually that would be pretty awful that
would be
pretty creepy feeling rather that
according to whether or not
your gut is alkaline or acidic in the
appropriate ways
you will populate your gut with the
appropriate microbiota
so you want your stomach to be pretty
acidic but
other elements of your digestive tract
are going to be more ph
and basically there's a gradient meaning
there's a low to high
ph gradient along the gut you don't have
to know what the ph
should be at any one given point because
you're not going to go and put
microbiota at one location and not
another
what you essentially want to do is
create an environment
where the proper microbiota can thrive
because when you do that
you greatly decrease what are called
inflammatory cytokines so these are
things that are secreted both by cells
within the body
and cells within the brain to impact
brain health and brain function and
bodily health
they go by particular name so there's
something called tnf alpha tumor
necrosis factor
alpha it is inflammatory it's not a good
thing to have
at elevated levels you have something
called interleukin-6 il-6
also causes inflammation causes damage
to tissues not a good thing to have
for elevated for long periods of time
and then you have
anti-inflammatory cytokines things like
interleukin 10 which reduce inflammation
and there are hundreds of these if not
thousands of these different cytokines
some of which promote inflammation
some of which reduce inflammation the
simple way
to adjust these things in the proper
ratios
is to adjust your gut microbiome the
best way to adjust your microbiome
is to ingest certain types of foods so
there is a beautiful literature on this
now but the most important literature
is the one that i referred to at the
beginning of this episode which is
what to ingest and what not to ingest in
terms of foods in order to create
the best conditions in your gut so that
you can create the best conditions in
your brain and body
there was a study done by my colleague
justin sonnenberg
at stanford school of medicine justin's
actually my upstairs neighbor
in the building at stanford where i work
and
they explored how different foods or
different diets i should say
impact the gut microbiome and
inflammatory markers and this is a
beautiful study because it was done in
hundreds of human patients these
actually weren't patients that were sick
i should say human subjects that were
otherwise healthy
from a huge variety of backgrounds so
you had men you had women you had people
of different races different
ethnicities you had a huge range of
backgrounds and they tracked all of that
and what they did is they explored two
types of diets one is a high fiber diet
so dietary fibers are non-digestible or
only partially digestible carbohydrates
typically
and they compared that to diets that
were unchanged except for the inclusion
of a few to a few more servings of
fermented foods each day
things like sauerkraut things like
kimchi they even explored
sounds pretty disgusting to me but who
knows i've never tried it which is
fermented cottage cheese
and what they found was that after
initial period of a few weeks where they
had people
either eat a lot of fiber or eat one or
two servings of fermented foods
they had those people ramp up their
ingestion of either fiber or fermented
food so they kind of eased them into it
so they went baseline then ramp up to
the point where they were ingesting you
know four or five servings of
fiber or of fermented foods per day
which sounds like a lot but for
fermented foods that would be
you know four or five tablespoons of
sauerkraut or kimchi it's not quite it's
not like huge platefuls of fermented
foods
and then they looked at a number of
things they looked at the proteome which
is a kind of like looking at the genome
but a bunch of proteins that are made in
the body
and they did this by fecal samples by
stool samples
and they did this by blood draw which is
great it's a real power of this study in
fact the most comprehensive
study that i'm aware of by looking at
these different tissues
across long periods of time so many many
weeks
and then returning people to their to
the diet that they were on before they
went into the study
they were were able to establish in a
causal way
how ingesting fibers or fibrous foods
versus ingesting these fermented foods
on a daily basis could impact the gut
microbiome
and many many inflammatory markers
and many many markers of immune function
and autoimmune function and the takeaway
message from this study
is that the fermented foods far
outperformed
the high fiber diet in fact the high
fiber diet in some people
was beneficial and in other people
caused issues with inflammation
this is very different than what i was
taught growing up and what many of us
were taught
interestingly they also observed that
people that ate the high fiber diet
had increases in certain enzymes that
lend themselves
to better digestion of carbohydrates and
i think there's an important insight to
come from this
nowadays we kind of live in the age of
extremes where people seem to either
want to be carnivore like never ingest a
vegetable like here they don't even
they're like a loud pepper but they're
not even allowed um
you know sauerkraut or something like
very extreme or
pure plant-based pure vegan or pure so
essentially
pure carbohydrate or pure animal protein
very extreme
i'm an omnivore i like to eat a mixture
of
different things at different times of
days but very extreme
but this is interesting because what
this what these data show is that
perhaps
ingesting a high carbohydrate high fiber
diet which is really what these the high
fiber
condition really was actually makes
people better
at digesting carbohydrates this may
explain why people who are used to a
kind of
more paleo type or or carnivore type
diet
might eat carbohydrates and say oh that
doesn't work for me i don't feel good
it might also explain why people who
predominantly eat plant-based foods
and carbohydrate foods will try eating
meat
as an experiment or because they lost a
bed or whatever it is and they'll do
or desperation or they'll do that and
then they'll say oh i don't feel good
when i eat meat
how good you feel it seems
how well you can utilize that food and
how much of that food
you crave may be determined in fact it
appears
is determined by your food eating
history the types of food you eat and i
think this might explain
some of the divide and hopefully might
bridge some of the chasm
between these different groups that are
saying it should be one way or it should
be another
but at the core of the study was the
bigger message the bigger message is
that all of us should be ingesting
on a regular basis daily basis two to
four servings of fermented foods of
different kinds and why
i say that is because the inflammatory
markers went down
the markers of autoimmune disruption
went down and the chemistry of the gut
therefore
was adjusted in the appropriate ways now
it's not to say that high fiber is bad
or that fiber is bad i don't want people
to confuse this
but even though this is a discussion
about interoception about sensing the
self
this is a subconscious mechanism by
which the gut
communicates to many many organs
including the brain and it's been shown
in other studies
also in quality peer-reviewed journals
that when
the correct gut microbiota are present
and these inflammatory markers are
reduced cognition improves so ability to
focus
ability to sleep ability to ward off
infection and wound healing
all enhanced in fact even in autism
spectrum disorder
in people that struggle with various
mental conditions or disorders of the
mind
improving the gut microbiome seems to
have powerful effects on improving
brain symptoms along the lines of
autoimmunity
there are a number of conditions that
we call autoimmune conditions and we
will do entire episodes about these
going forward but for people with
so-called
irritable bowel syndrome for people with
crohn's disease for people with leaky
gut
hashimoto's which is a kind of an immune
system
self-attack on one's thyroid gland and
things like eczema skin conditions
adjusting the gut microbiome has been
shown to be useful
in positively adjusting the symptoms
of all of those will it fix those
conditions entirely probably not but can
it have a significant positive impact on
them
probably yes there is one thing that's
worth mentioning in that list which is
leaky gut
what is leaky gut here we're talking
about the guts what is it to have a
leaky gut
it sounds awful it sounds like something
sort of like leaking out the the end of
the tube
and maybe that too i don't know but
leaky gut is actually because
your gut is not a tube that's continuous
one cell it's actually made up of many
many cells and those cells form
a barrier and they form what are called
tight
junctions so if you have two cells and
you want to create a fence out of those
cells
you bind them together the way that the
body does this is to bind them together
with what are called tight junctions
these are
they go by names like cloudins and
things like that if you want to look
them up
these tight junctions form a nice
barrier like a cyclone fence
that things can't get past but like a
cyclone fence only
molecules of a certain size can go
through those holes so you're not going
to pass a soccer ball through
an intact cyclone fence but you could
pass for instance a feather
through that fence so leaky gut
is when the conditions in the gut are
too alkaline or the gut microbiota
are off in the gut meaning microbiota
that like
alkaline guts are living there and those
tight junctions
can't function at that particular ph and
you create little holes
in that fence and then what happens is
when you ingest foods
some of those foods literally leak out
of the gut and into
the extracellular space and into the
bloodstream
and because foods include proteins
and antibodies react to proteins what
ends up happening in leaky gut
and the reason we talk about in
autoimmune conditions is that you start
developing
antibodies to particular food proteins
and then
people start feeling like they have food
allergies and they do they actually
create particular food allergies
now one way to prevent leaky gut is to
get the rest of the gut situation happy
by ingesting the proper foods that we
talked about before ingesting fermented
foods on a regular basis
the other is our old friend glutamine
again
there are some data and i should say
it's a limited number of studies showing
that ingesting glutamine
anywhere from one to three excuse me
teaspoons per day
can help alleviate leaky gut now the
mechanism for that still isn't clear
whether or not it's adjusting ph
or whether or not it's creating more
favorable
environment for the microbiota but it is
clear that
supplementing with glutamine can in some
people enhance
or i should say improve conditions of
leaky gut so that might be useful as
well
and then the final thing about this i
want to talk about as we're talking
about chemical sensing
in the gut and how that impacts
well-being is
about gut acidity and this i confess is
a little bit controversial
some people are on board this other
people are not and so i'd love your
feedback on this
if you um if you agree please tell me if
you disagree please tell me but please
tell me why you disagree
in particular experience or data
although
it's always better if you can point me
towards peer-reviewed studies
there is a practice that some people
embrace i'm not recommending people
necessarily do this and you would
definitely want to talk to your doctor
but
where people have food allergies or
they're having mood or autoimmune issues
and they treat this some people
recommend treating this through the
ingestion of hcl hydrochloric acid
tablets now hydrochloric acid can burn
you right acids can burn you they
literally can
melt away skin you want to be very
careful with acids of all kinds
truly but hydrochloric acid is
sold as in supplement form in capsular
pill form
and there is a practice of starting to
ingest one
or two hydrochloric acid tablets midway
through a meal
and then what people will generally do
is examine to see whether or not that
improves
their symptoms of indigestion how it
relates to mood
how it relates to well-being how it
relates to their sensation of their gut
viscera by changing the acidity you also
change the way that the gut communicates
with the brain through the mechanisms we
talked about before
and there are a growing number of people
embracing these practices of taking
hcl it's often combined with other
things it's usually
um combined with it with an enzyme
and that enzyme is pepsin
so most of these supplements come in the
form betaine hcl pepsin
and while they're not a cure-all i
certainly don't want to suggest that
they're a cure-all
many people that have a hard time
adjusting the ph of their gut
and have a hard time adjusting the
microbiota of their gut in the
appropriate ways
have benefited from taking these betaine
hcl pepsin
tablets or capsules during meals and the
general instruction is to start slow to
start with one or two
and then to find a level that you're
comfortable with that doesn't create
an excessive feeling of warmth in this
in the stomach that doesn't throw off
your digestion so it takes a little bit
of experimentation again definitely
talk to your health care provider before
exploring this
but this has become a very common
practice for people with autoimmune
disorders and accessing the gut
because it is accessible by taking
things has also become
way in which people with various mental
conditions are
trying to adjust their mood and adjust
their well-being
along these lines i i do want to mention
that there are studies that show that
people that supplement with a lot of
probiotics or even prebiotics can
sometimes
experience brain fog this isn't
discussed a lot and
the data are a little all over the place
but it is worth thinking about
the goal here is not to create as many
microbiota as possible what you want is
microbiota diversity and i should
mention this again in reference to the
sonnenberg study
which was what the high fiber diet does
is it increases certain microbiota but
it limits their diversity
and what the fermented food diet does or
i should say the diet that includes
regular ingestion of fermented foods a
few servings a day
is it increases microbiota diversity
now lack of microbiota diversity has
a name in the medical profession it's
called dysbiosis and dysbiosis is bad
dysbiosis is what you see
when people are spending long periods of
time on bed rest
or when they've been chronically ill and
so
here again we're talking about creating
a
positive environment in the gut either
by adjusting acidity maybe you explore
the betaine hcl pepsin thing
i think if you have healthy digestion if
you feel like you have a good
relationship to your gut and it has a
good relationship to you sort of a
silly phrase because it is you and you
are it um
then i don't think there's any means or
any need to
pursue this but if you don't that might
be one avenue to pursue however i think
primary in all of this is the fermented
food findings
and it's not just one study it's many
many findings that now bring us to a
place where a huge center of mass of
data are pointing us in the direction of
saying
ingest fermented foods on a regular
basis
i should also mention that conditions
like sarcopenia
which is the loss of muscle tissue as we
age has been shown to be offset by
improving the gut microbiota so while
today is about interoception we're
talking about
sensing we're also talking about
subconscious sensing what are we talking
about subconscious sensing we're talking
about subconscious sensing
of the milieu of the body when the
milieu of the gut in the body
is right then the brain and the immune
system
function very well and so this isn't
something where you can sit back and say
oh you know i feel all those good
microbiota in my gut
or oh no those are bad microbiota you
can't do that unless you're gonna take
fecal samples and
um and blood samples and analyze them in
the with the extreme
uh exhaustive nature that the sonnenberg
and other labs do
you're not going to get that kind of
information i know there are companies
out there
that do this and i i don't want to knock
on any of them
but i do want to emphasize that to do
this right to really analyze
which cytokines you're making and which
ones you're not you really need to look
at a huge number of them and that
requires large-scale proteomic and
genomic
and inflammatory marker screens it's
just not the kind of thing that most
commercial enterprises can really
provide to people in a way that they can
interpret
rather this is a case where you can
simply go to the effector to the thing
that can actually move the needle in the
right direction for you
it's very clear that's fermented foods
and that's keeping the stomach
slightly more acid than one might think
you would want to
so let's talk about barfing first
barfing
aka vomiting is when
the contents of your guts run in reverse
meaning when they go up from your
stomach sometimes even up from the
intestines even though that sounds
horrible it sometimes happens
up out the esophagus and mouth and
onto whatever surface happens to be in
front of you it's a terrible thing
nobody likes to do it
but it's a very interesting aspect to
our biology because it reveals
a beautiful and absolutely fundamental
relationship between
our chemistry and our brain
so your brain is actually locked behind
a gate
and that gate is not your skull that
gate
is the so-called blood-brain barrier so
just like your gut
has these epithelial tight junctions the
things i talked about before
that provide a fence so things can't get
through and get through in leaky gut
your brain has tight junctions that are
very very tight
it's absolutely fundamental that only
certain molecules
get across the blood-brain barrier and
that others don't and the reason for
that
is that most all 99.99
of your neurons do not regenerate i
don't care what you've read
especially in the news recently about
how psychedelics cause neurogenesis
because they don't
it's absolutely wrong psychedelics have
effects on brain plasticity but they
have nothing to do with neurogenesis at
least no data support it
but because you can't make new neurons
you also can't damage the ones you've
got or you shouldn't as much as possible
and that's why you have a blood
brain barrier or a bbb so
the bbb as it's called
prevents substances from getting to the
brain
however like any fence
it is not always uniform along its
length
and there are little spots within that
fence where
chemicals can sneak across to the brain
and through a beautiful design i don't
know
anything about the design as i always
say i wasn't consulted the design phase
so i'm not talking about
any kind of intelligent design or
anything that is not the topic of this
podcast this is not a philosophy podcast
nor is it a religion podcast it's a
science podcast
but through a beautiful design of some
sort
there are little holes in that fence and
they're little neurons
that sit right behind those holes and
those neurons
sense what the chemistry of the blood is
so i'm guessing you probably didn't
imagine that today's discussion about
sensing the self would be sensing your
own blood
but you do there's a little area of your
brain that's little
indeed but is very very important called
area postrama
p-o-s-t-r-e-m-a
an area postrama is an area of the brain
stem
that sits right next to another brain
area called the chemoreceptor trigger
zone
and when the contents in your
bloodstream
are of a particular kind meaning when
there are pathogens
or it's too acidic the neurons in area
posttrauma
and the neurons in the chemo receptor
trigger zone the ctz as it's called
trigger a bunch of motor reflexes in the
abdominal
wall that make you barf
okay the contr the feeling that you need
to throw up
is triggered by these neurons in the
brain stem and those neurons in the
brainstem are triggered
by the presence of certain chemicals and
the reason why you don't have any
blood-brain barrier at that location
is because posttrauma has to be there
like a crossing guard
making sure that everything that's
coming through the blood is okay
and if it even senses just the tiniest
bit that things are off
it's going to trigger that reflex now
the really interesting thing is that the
neurons in area postdrama
respond to the chemistry of the blood
but they also will respond
to our consciousness to things that we
think and things that we believe
and even particular memories this is why
when certain people see vomit or see
someone else vomit or even somebody else
heaving as if they're going to vomit
they themselves feel as if they're going
to vomit
i'm guessing there are probably even a
few of you right now that feel like you
might
vomit you might feel saliva salivation
in your throat which is always a
precursor to vomiting
some people the memory of or the thought
of something like blood
or vomit or use your imagination can
actually trigger
the vomit reflex and that's because
these neurons in area postrama
are very sensitive to prior experience
of interactions
with negative things so and actually as
i'm saying this i feel my gut kind of
cramping up again i'm
i'm i don't vomit very easily i'm not
one of those
nor am i somebody who's never vomited
and here we are talking about my vomit
history
but i think it's appropriate in this in
this context the neurons of aryapostrema
are there basically to keep your whole
system safe
and thank goodness they are because for
instance
some people unfortunately they they
drink so much
alcohol that they throw up have you ever
wondered why that is well it's because
alcohol fundamentally is a poison i'm
not saying for
you know age-appropriate folks that
ingesting alcohol is bad
this isn't a judgment call but alcohol
itself
at excessive levels in the bloodstream
triggers postrama to cause
vomiting so this is an example whereby
memories context but also just the
chemistry of our internal state is
triggering behaviors that are very
hardwired they're very reflex driven and
why would it be that some people
get more nauseous than others at a given
level well they'll have to do with
alcohol tolerance
some people have what's called a you
know we refer to as a stronger stomach
or a stomach of steel
other people they throw up very easily
if they don't
feel well or if they ingest anything
that's just a little bit off
from a purely adaptive standpoint
it's probably better to vomit up things
that aren't good for you rather than to
pass through
have them pass through your system
especially if those things
are contained in lipids for instance if
you ingest something that's in lipid
form because
cells literally every cell in your body
is surrounded by a little thin layer of
fatty tissue
we call the bile air membrane it's a
little membrane fat can move through
fat very easily and so any bad stuff you
ingest can get stuck in your system
so let's talk for a second about how to
reduce nausea
because nausea that salivation that
feeling that you're going to vomit
can be very beneficial and in an
adaptive circumstance
like you've ingested something bad but
some people experience nausea
for other reasons there are good ways to
regulate
nausea and the ways they regulate nausea
are very interesting they actually
adjust the activity
of these neurons in area postrema or
they change the chemistry of the blood
directly and many of you have heard this
before perhaps but it turns out that
there are good
data 11 research studies were the ones
that i could find peer-reviewed research
studies with no
bias so independent studies showing that
ginger
can cause a notable reduction
in nausea how much ginger one to three
grams what's one to three grams well you
have to measure it out on a scale unless
you're taking it in pillar capsule form
it doesn't seem to matter if you take it
in pill or capsule form
so this thing that you've heard before
that ginger
can reduce nausea indeed is true
peppermint apparently can also do that
and some of you
will not be surprised to learn that
cannabis can reduce nausea
not surprised because cannabis which has
different legality in different places
and i understand that so please take
that into consideration
but cannabis thc and or
it turns out cbd can reduce nausea
that's been shown in at least one study
and it probably does that not by
changing the chemistry of your blood but
by
changing the threshold for firing of
these neurons in areapostrema
and there are conditions such as in
chemotherapy and radiation therapy and
others
where people are feeling very nauseous
i'm not recommending people go use
cannabis unless
they've decided with their selves and
their family and their doctor that they
should
but what's interesting is this thing
about cbd and we'll do a whole episode
on thc and cbd cbd doesn't have
or isn't supposed to have these
psychoactive properties that thc does
although cbd can have a mild to major
anxiety anxiety reducing effect
but it does appear that the data are
what
uh the data supports i should say uh the
anecdotal
reports which are that cannabis can
reduce
uh nausea so tabarf less ginger
peppermint and if appropriate and legal
for you possibly cannabis
now let's talk about fever in previous
episodes
and in future episodes we deal with
thermal regulation which is the body's
ability to regulate its temperature
talk about cold and heat and saunas and
ice baths and
physical performance we're not going to
deal with all that right now
but i promise we will going forward
today i only want to talk about
fever because fever directly relates to
enteroception
what do i mean by that well a fever is
simply an increase in body temperature
that increase in body temperature is
triggered by neurons in the brain
and those neurons in the brain are
triggered by the presence of particular
things in the bloodstream
what sorts of things well toxins
bacteria viruses when something bad gets
in our system
the body doesn't know it's bad it just
knows it's foreign and it hasn't seen it
before
or that it's in the wrong compartment of
the body so earlier we were talking
about proteins that leak out of the gut
and get elsewhere
you know you don't want a piece of steak
sitting in your bicep that would be bad
you would actually develop antibodies
you would have a horrible infection
but your body has this intelligence and
that intelligence is to know
hmm these proteins are normally not seen
in this region
and then your body or the cells there i
should say will release something
that then will travel to the brain and
will trigger
an increase in body temperature so that
your body cooks the bad thing
or the cause of the bad thing it's
really a beautiful adaptive mechanism we
always think fever is so terrible but
fever is there
to cook the bad thing that's inside you
or that has
left the correct compartment inside you
and is in the wrong compartment
inside you so what's beautiful about the
fever mechanism
is that it looks a lot like the barfing
mechanism basically you have a set of
neurons
that sit near the ventricles remember
the ventricles this hole
in the tube that is you the tube that is
you
you are a tube a series of tubes and
your brain has a hole down the middle
and it extends down to the bottom of
your spinal cord
at the front it's called the ventricles
they start with what are called the
lateral ventricles and the
excuse me starts with the third and the
lateral ventricles and then it goes to
the fourth ventricle and then to what's
called the central canal but basically
it's just a big space
in the middle of your nervous system the
middle of your brain and you have one
ventricle that i already mentioned
called the third ventricle
and it's shaped kind of like a thin oval
up
upright if you're listening to this just
think an eye just seeing the shape of an
eye but it's kind of rotated
90 degrees so it's up and down as
opposed to across
and along that third ventricle there's
there are little neurons that can sense
what's in the cerebral spinal fluid that
fills the ventricle so in other words
you have neurons that are sensing the
chemistry of your cerebral spinal fluid
and that have access therefore to
the chemistry of your body because that
cerebral spinal fluid
is going up and down the brain and
spinal cord but into that cerebrospinal
fluid
are signals about the various chemicals
within the body so this is not a
mechanical system this is a chemical
system remember we're talking about
mechanical information and chemical
information
accessing the brain so if you have
something
bad in your system you've ingested a
viru you breathed in a virus
or you inhaled some bacteria or you got
a cut on your leg and some bacteria are
growing there
of course locally there will be effects
little things called
mast cells m-a-s-t little packets of
histamine literally will go there and
explode
and cause inflammation which is actually
a good inflammation and we'll
release little things called macrophages
try to gobble up the infection
the other day it was in texas there was
a mean little mosquitoes in texas and a
lot of them
and i would stand outside and i'd get
bitten i didn't feel a thing but then
later that night
they started swelling up and itching and
then i'd itch them and then they'd swell
even more that was because the release
of mast cells
of histamines inside those mast cells
that were literally causing inflammation
of the tissue it wasn't the poison from
the mosquito itself
it was the immune response to those well
you also have this systemic or body-wide
attempt to kill stuff
and that's the fever so the neurons that
line these ventricles with cerebral
spinal fluid go by a particular name
they're called circumventricular organs
meaning
near circumventricular near the
ventricles
and you have these organs and there's a
set of neurons has a really cool name
called the ovlt
i don't know why i like that but i just
like it it's the organum vasculosum of
the lateral
terminolous organ and vascularism
lateral terminalis
ovlt are the neurons that respond to
toxins and bad stuff in your bloodstream
however minor or major
and they release things like ilk1
which are inflammatory cytokines
inflammatory in this case is good you
want inflammation at the site of an
infection it's a good thing it's going
to help with healing
and it's going to change the conditions
in your body what's going to happen is
when those ovlt neurons are activated
because you have something bad in your
body or something
bad is happening in your body they
communicate with an area of the brain
called the
pre-optic area of your hypothalamus and
the pre-optic area
cranks up your temperature and tries to
cook that bad thing
now it's worth talking about fever for a
moment
and talking about thermal regulation
because i think this actually could save
some lives
so if you are overheated
to a point where you know you're getting
up past 102 or 103 it's going to vary
depending on person to person and
certainly age you know kids
some people think can tolerate higher
levels of fever than adults but look
you always want to be cautious about
heating up the brain too much because
once those neurons are gone they do not
come back and neurons do not do well in
very high
temperatures once your body temperature
starts getting up to 102 103.
certainly 104 you are starting to enter
serious danger zone
this can happen through exercise in hot
environments
or an inability to escape heat because
you don't have covering or
adequate ventilation or cooling it can
also be because of excessive fever for
whatever reason
a lot of people think the way to deal
with this is to put a cool compress on
the back of the neck
or to cool the torso
in discussing this with my colleague
craig heller who's
at stanford school of medicine and he's
on the undergraduate side of the campus
as well
runs a biology lab he's a world expert
in thermal regulation
it's very clear that that's the wrong
response to try and cool off the body
if you put a cold towel or you put an
ice pack on the back of the neck what
you effectively do is cool the blood
that's going to the brain
and if you do that then your brain will
react
by turning up the crank in so to speak
on the neurons in the pre-optic area and
will heat you up further and can cook
your brain and organs
further so what you want to do is as
i've talked about before you want to
cool
the bottoms of the feet the palms of the
hands and the upper part of the face
i'm not going to go into all the details
as to why you want to do that right now
but those are the locations you want to
cool now you can also cool the rest of
the body
but it's not okay to just stay under the
covers and just
cool uh you know the neck or something
like that you really want to
try and create a systemic or whole body
cooling if the goal is to bring fever
down
but in many cases fever is adaptive and
so taking
uh non-steroid anti-inflammatory drugs
like um
advil and tylenol sometimes can be good
if that's recommended but other times
because it reduces your fever it's
allowing
that pathogen that pyrogen it's
sometimes called a pyrogen is a
substance that causes fever think pyro
think
fire think pyromaniacs think pyro
those pyrogens can survive it moderate
to low temperatures and they can't
survive at high temperatures so the
fever is an adaptive mechanism and the
ovlt and the sensing
of your chemistry is how the ovlt organ
vasculosum in the lateral terminalis
does that so we've talked about sensing
lung volume speed of our heartbeat we
talked about sensing
the gut volume the intestinal volume or
the absence of volume we talked about
chemistry of the gut and the gut
microbiota
and autoimmune functions and we've now
talked about
vomiting and we've talked about fever
lots of aspects of sensing our internal
self
now i want to turn our attention to
interoception as it relates to
feelings the way that interception is
most commonly described
and i want to highlight a term that many
of you have probably heard which is the
vagus nerve
we talked about vegas a little bit
earlier but the vagus nerve this
vagabonding wandering nerve is involved
in
everything i've talked about up until
now and the reason i
saved it till now rather than mentioning
all along is to highlight
a specific point which is that whenever
we hear about the vegas
in popular culture it's like the vegas
calms you down you want to stimulate the
vegas by rubbing in front of the ear
and it's a parasympathetic nerve and it
will calm you down it'll mellow you out
actually
most of the time the vagus is
stimulatory when you ingest foods
with amino acids sugars or fatty acids
the vagus nerve gets activated and
triggers the release of dopamine and
makes you
more alert and go seek more of those
foods or what led to those conditions
when you feel nauseous it's rarely
calming when you feel like you have a
fever it's rarely calming
so you're starting to get the picture
that even though the vagus
nerve is in the parasympathetic branch
of the autonomic nervous system and if
that doesn't mean anything to you
because you're not an aficionado don't
worry about it
but it's not a calming system it's a
communication system
and it's a motor system it communicates
brain to body and body to brain
and it changes the function of different
organs now
one thing that's important to highlight
is that
stress itself will alter the chemistry
of your gut
because of the ways that it shuts down
the vagus nerve and quiets the neurons
that communicate from gut to brain
i want to say that again stress will
disrupt your gut
and make you feel not good poor
digestion and just lousy
because of the way that it shuts down
the vagus nerve and the neurons of your
gut
so what stress does is it blocks the
communication
between gut and brain it doesn't mess up
your gut it just doesn't let your gut
get the signals up to your brain
and it also then throws off the
chemistry and then there's a whole
cascade of effects
if you want to learn more about stress i
did a whole episode called master
stress or i think maybe it was called
conquer stress and it was master stress
either one the whole point of that
episode is to give you tools and
practices to deal with short-term
acute stress moderate term stress and
long-term chronic stress
through behavioral mechanisms nutrition
supplementation
and many other things as well it's
chock-a-block full of protocols and
tools for stress
the vagus nerve however is responsible
for
emotion and the way it does that is to
pool
to aggregate the conditions of your gut
the conditions of your heart and the
conditions of your breathing
which includes your diaphragm and lungs
and takes that
kind of as a a collection of information
and sends it to the brain and controls
what we call
your emotions now that might seem
obvious to some people
but to other people that might seem
totally crazy you thought your emotions
were because the market was down and you
had
invested or because something that you
thought was going to happen
is not going to happen or because you
thought that
school was going to open and then it's
not or maybe you thought it wasn't and
it is
whatever it is that bothers you you
think of generally as a purely cognitive
event
but the brain doesn't really know what
to do with that information
it doesn't act directly on that
information to create moods
moods are created through the heart's
response to reading that headline
to the change in your breathing that's
caused by someone that you love telling
you
that actually they're not interested in
spending time with you anymore or that
you screwed up or
that they're interested in spending a
lot of time with you and you like that
right emotions can be good or bad or
neutral
so this thing that we call interoception
the sense of self i've been building up
from very fundamental layers
gut chemistry spleens immune systems
autoimmune
and you might have been thinking wait i
thought this was going to be about a
sense of self
a noticing or a feeling and indeed
all of those things are plugging in like
a series of ingredients in a recipe
that gives rise to your mood and how you
feel
and that mood and how you feel
is shown in one location in your body
that other people can see
and that's in your facial expressions
and indeed there are now beautiful data
showing that your face
including the size of your pupils the
tonality of your face how flushed you
are
or how pale you are even the degree to
which you are frowning
or smiling relative to other periods of
time
that is all an aggregate
of or a reflection rather of your gut
your heart
and your breathing and the chemistry of
your body and so this is why i sort of
backed into this conversation about
interoception i kind of trojan horse
this on you
on purpose which is that when we talk
about the vagus and you hear oh you know
you can get vagal tone by breathing or
rubbing on the front of the ear sure
that's probably true but
another fundamental layer is the acidity
of your gut how fast you're breathing
are you inhale emphasized or inhale
or exhale emphasize breathing when we
are
relaxed our pupils tend to constrict
when we are very alert our pupils tend
to be dilated whether or not that
alertness has to do
with being happy or being sad and what's
remarkable and this is where
interoception
really really takes a leap into the
incredible
is that there are beautiful studies that
show that for instance
when we know somebody pretty well and
they are going through some sort of
experience
of any kind our heart rate actually
starts to mimic
their heart rate our breathing starts to
mimic their breathing even if we aren't
conscious
of their breathing it's not like we see
their chest heaving
and we think oh my goodness and then we
breathe that way
there's a mirroring and no it's not
carried out through mirror neurons
mirror neurons are more of a myth and a
reality sorry to burst
people's bubbles but that bubble around
mirror neurons is definitely made of
myths
and a topic for another time but we
start to mirror
somehow human beings are able to
register
the internal state of other beings and i
think probably for animals too but
certainly for other humans
even at a distance and these studies are
many now and they're really wonderful
studies
and so your sense of your internal
landscape
is linked to others now you can enhance
this interoceptive capacity for how you
feel and how others feel in other words
you can start getting a better readout
of your internal state
by doing a simple exercise what is
really a tool
and that is to learn to sense your
heartbeats
so some people are very good at this
other people are not
some people can do this more easily when
they have all their air exhaled and some
people can do it better when they
are holding a breath hold but one thing
that's kind of
cool about this whole enteroceptive
capacity
is that you can enhance it very very
quickly you can
learn or teach yourself to have
heightened levels of interception
in a way that you can't really just give
yourself heightened levels of vision
by snapping your fingers in one one
round of one tool or exercise there are
things you can do to improve vision
that's the topic of a previous episode i
encourage you to look it up there are
things you can do to improve your
hearing
and your taste and your smell we talked
about all those
but with interoception you can get very
good at this
very fast and i think this is one of the
reasons why meditation is powerful
i think there are a lot of reasons why
meditation is powerful but one of the
reasons is when you stop
taking in exteroceptive information
information from the outside world
by closing your eyes and focusing inward
as they say
you start paying attention to your
breathing cadence you start directing
your mind's
attention to your heart rate and if you
can start to
perceive your heart beating you actually
are
very quickly strengthen the vagal
connections between the body and the
brain
and so there's no real practice here
there's no breathe this way or do this
thing
except to direct your awareness
toward your heartbeat and some people
can get very good at this very fast most
people find that just by doing this for
a minute or so every once in a while
they start to tap into this sixth sense
they start to notice
when they don't feel quite right about
something or somebody or some situation
or they start to notice when they feel
quite right
about somebody or something or some
situation so this interoceptive
awareness can be
tuned up it used to be called vagal tone
but i think that term doesn't take into
account all the other things that are
going on with the vegas so i don't
really like
that term it's more of an interroceptive
awareness
and again there are many studies now
showing
that forsake of bettering one's mood
overall
for sake of moving through a challenging
phase in life for sake
of just enhancing one's experience of
life overall whether or not it's the
taste of foods interactions with other
people
enjoyment focus pleasure
tuning up one's interroceptive awareness
is both easy
again by just taking a minute or two and
trying to count heartbeats
and then this works best of course if
you have some independent readout of
heartbeats and you can compare you can
see how accurate your
you are but even even if you don't use a
device or have a device to do that
without taking your pulse using your
thumb on your wrist or something or your
fingers on your neck
as you typically would for taking your
pulse trying to
sit still for a minute or two every once
in a while maybe once a week maybe twice
a week
maybe while you're meditating maybe
while breath work maybe during the
breath holds of breath work you don't
really have to do this in any kind of
extended way
you can very quickly increase your
interoceptive tone and that has a huge
and outsized effect
on the brain body relationship and your
brain's ability to tap into both the
subconscious and the conscious aspects
of this chemical and mechanical
signaling that's happening all the time
and it can have real and outsized
positive effects on your ability
to engage with other people and your
ability to focus at work
and your ability to notice ah i'm
finding myself
kind of feeling like i'm losing focus
but really it was my heart rate was just
increasing maybe i just
exhale a little bit and bring my heart
rate down
so what i've effectively tried to do
today is to give you a window into this
incredible relationship
between your viscera and your brain and
your brain and your visceral all these
organs of your body
and i what i hope is that you'll
appreciate
that it's a system that you aren't just
a system of tubes
i said that in sort of ingest i mean you
have a lot of tubes and you are a system
of tubes but that system of tubes is
linked through the nervous system and
those links work in very
specific ways so whether or not you
remember about piezos and all the glp1rs
and all that stuff it doesn't really
matter
what i encourage you to do is start sort
of pushing and pulling on the various
levers within this beautiful system that
we call the interroceptive system this
sense of self
if you're learning from this podcast and
or if you're enjoying it please
subscribe to our youtube channel that
really helps us
also on the youtube channel please leave
us comments and feedback
including feedback of topics you'd like
to see in future episodes or guests
you'd like to see on future episodes we
do read all the comments
in addition please subscribe on apple
and spotify
and follow us on instagram at huberman
lab
if you want to leave us a five star
review on apple you also have the
opportunity to leave us a five star
review
you can also leave us comments and
feedback on apple
during the course of today's episode and
on previous episodes i mentioned
supplements i realize supplements aren't
for everybody
but for those of you that are interested
in supplements it is important
that the supplements that you take have
a high level of stringency
with respect to the amounts of the
contents that are listed on the bottle
matching what's actually in the bottle
in the capsules and tablets and that the
quality of those ingredients be
extremely high for that reason
we partnered with thorn that's
t-h-o-r-n-e because
thorn supplements have the highest
levels of stringency for both the
content
and the amount of content in those
bottles and supplements
if you want to try thorn supplements and
you want to see the supplements that i
take you can go to thorne.com
the letter u huberman and you can see
all the supplements that i take you can
get 20
off any of those and if you enter the
thorn site through that portal
you can get 20 off any of the
supplements that thorne makes
in addition we have a patreon account
it's patreon.com
andrew huberman there you can support
the podcast at any level that you like
please also visit us at hubermannlab.com
and sign up for our free newsletter
our newsletter starts in august 2021
and you'll be receiving protocols and
excerpts from podcasts
some condensed information that we think
will really be of value to you it's
totally zero cost again
just go to hubermanlab.com and sign up
for what we call our neural network
newsletter and most of all thank you for
your time and attention
and thank you for your interest in
[Music]
science